Rison wondering if we can talk a little
bit about life before
comrade detectives and when you were
starting out in the entertainment
industry what was your strategy did you
have a strategy did you end up here
accidentally yeah and so there's a
strategy at least I didn't know with one
eye I mean where I grew up was about as
far from the film industry as as could
be well not as give me I'm sure I could
grown up in Siberia too but I grew up in
a small village in South Wales and
really had zero idea of you know how you
might penetrate a film industry or
television and yeah it was sort of just
through lucky I mean again I think me
taking some risks and some Gamble's and
then and then some happy accidents that
I sort of found my way eventually to SML
there's a so long story between
obviously but yeah I essentially I came
I went to New York knowing again I
wanted to work in film television no
idea what to do
New York seems like the direction to
head LA felt like too much of a cultural
leap at the time and and yeah I you know
I just I had about five jobs it's sort
of my first six months hours of catering
and working in stores and all that stuff
and then luckily I got a job in a post
production facility the edited
commercials and I was working the
receptionist and that was there for up
to two weeks I think when Jim Signorelli
who is the longtime film director at SNL
as it came in to work on something and I
just thought we ended up chatting and at
at lunch time and randomly about two
weeks after that he called up and just
said the assistant was leaving and did I
want to come and work for him so that
was kind of my beginning because I
didn't go to film school I studied
theater so it was a real we're the
fortuitous place to land because the
film unit SNL is this sort of machine in
film production where we're producing
films you know from start to finish in
three days every week and when I started
they're still shooting on film as well
so it was a really amazing you know
place to land and you know suddenly be
on set and so yeah that's why I kind of
went that and then work my way up very
slowly and yeah and Here I am well
that's fascinating too from that is you
never know who you'll run into you don't
exactly be polite to strangers and yeah
I mean again it was it's there's
definitely moments when I've sort of
made a choice to you know maybe be more
aggressive or to sort of you know you
cannot you do have to assert yourself
and and you know I take chances because
I don't think you'll ever have the right
amount of experience that someone's
looking for so you know that's an L for
example my sort of let my trajectory
sort of follow the pattern the first few
years of me like the SNL season is like
a school years ago September to May and
then you have the summer off you know
and you can you know obviously go to
other things or not work but I usually
would go and work on something else and
and then each you know September would
roll around then my first few years I
never knew if I was going to get hired
again the next season but you know I'd
in every a phone call would come with
with Jim and you know I'd usually sort
of just maybe embellish a little bit
about what I'd done that summer just
have elevate my my experience so I
quickly sort of went from being a PA to
a production coordinator the following
season and then and then I was line
producer as my third year at SNL I was
line producing the film in it and
completely flying by the seat of my
pants I had no idea what I was doing and
it was way in over my head but you know
we Bo we got through it and and then I
did that for about I was the line pretty
severe for about five or six years
before I made the moves of directing and
that's a whole other thing too were you
googling things on your lunch hour like
okay how do I do this oh sure I can get
production is I will forever the design
producer position is really
is one of those thankless positions I
mean you know I commend people that that
do it enjoy it and and a good at it
because it's the to me it's on the house
jobs on set because you know you're
absorbing all of the responsibilities
that should really the sort of practical
responsibilities is you you know so if
if a PA doesn't wake up and get in his
truck and bring a camera to set or the
stage is locked or an actor doesn't show
up for you know what all the myriad of
things are the weather doesn't cooperate
it all basically comes back to you to
solve obviously the directors there
creatively to you know constantly has to
be doing the dance to solve the problems
but as the line producer obviously
that's it you know you you're the one
who's got to keep the machine running
and you know keep the budget in line all
kind of stuff and so it's really really
hard and very very stressful so I again
that was that that was the sort of the
terrifying learning experience which
sort of suddenly realizing that your
exposure was everything you know so yeah
it's I don't think it's only Google you
can only again I think some people's
personalities are made for it I don't
think I was I sort of managed to do it
for all those years and again for me it
was an amazing learning experience
because you can you you know by becoming
responsibility for everybody you
inevitably had to learn about every you
know position on set because you
obviously have to troubleshoot at any
time anyone had an issue so you get to
know you know the grit department and
their equipment needs and what they do
and the electricians and the bad
Department should so it was a really
good way just for me to really learn my
way all around within the same through
post-production again I just got really
like out of land in this weird film
school as an hour and you know it was on
on-the-job training yeah what's with the
stress of knowing that you may not come
back exactly yeah exactly so you always
kind of again you never rest on your
laurels so take everything as I will you
know I'm going to keep going as far as I
can and you know because who knows like
I might be looking for another job soon
you know like not that they encourage an
environment of insecurity but you know I
think it helps keep moving forwards you
know not to get complacent yeah sounds
like good like training right yeah so it
then doing Conrad detectives sounds like
it was much easier because I know you
shot this on spec and you had an over
to the Eastern Bloc location scout yes
yeah I would say the easier I mean I
think you know as SNL's been amazing
training I think for for a lot of
production circumstances I think I'm
more comfortable with you know the
last-minute things and sort of change it
and I think I've learnt an agility that
maybe some people don't necessarily have
to go through through working on SNL so
it helped because there was definitely
you know a sort of fish out of water
quality to accept getting to Romania and
getting to know Romanian crew
determining customs of figuring out how
this whole machine was going to work and
we had a very tight schedule dose of
ludicrously tight schedule for what we
ended up doing and and again I think
yeah it's not Tommy the stupidity and
the naivety to to just take it on and go
for it
yeah and not knowing is actually better
yeah yeah I I think I'm have a weird
addiction to to people people freaking
out around and trying to find a way
through okay well that's an art in
itself and some people are actually
really well suited for that so yeah off
to you everybody I don't think I do want
a battle but yes at that time I'm good
you're good at talking people down right
again when you're presented with a
script how can you tell good writing
versus bad writing I mean there's
there's writing that maybe with a few
more iterations would be excellent and
then there's things that you know this
just isn't going to work has a really
good question a comedy as well is a very
specific thing because um you know there
are writers that are really good at
jokes you know and can really you know
they're just really funny people but
maybe sometimes don't necessarily
understand story you know such the
structure might be so you might read
something on the surface has some really
good beats but as a whole it just
doesn't do together so I think the thing
that I tend to look for first in in any
script yeah is a sense of story does
that you know does this person sort of
know the story that they're telling and
you know did they understand the sort of
structure of things unique and again
it's a sort of subtle thing that you
come to to see analysis also is a story
that that you know that I like I mean as
you know it's like anything that there
are films and scripts and what-have-you
they're not for everybody so you know I
can't I'm a sort of nine joy script but
it's not because it's not good maybe
it's just not I'm not the person for it
but but ya know I mean a story is
definitely a thing that I think most
writers if they can get a good handle on
studying that and understanding
character and and you know and
motivations what have you that that's
that's the sort of foundation that joke
writing and stuff I think you know if
you can do that as well and then you're
on a good track but it's really funny so
it's quite rare to see people who can
kind of straddle both things
so then how did you meet Bryan Gatewood
and Alessandro Tanaka it was through
this project I came in to I met with
John Hodges a 24 and he mentioned in the
meeting this weird idea that these guys
come to him with and I you know I
thought it sounded intriguing and it was
you know I just I would think I just
done season one of documentary now and
you know so it was in a similar vein it
felt similarly the you know sort of like
an exploration of a sort of film genre
and also the fact that there was you
know it was foreign set was really
appealing to me so anyway I was
interested in I said you know I sort of
told them I was a fan at the time I was
at SNL and doing documentary now so I
sort of thought well it sounds great but
you know unfortunately I don't think I
can do it but yeah good luck and I know
at six months later they called me up
and said you know we shall haven't done
it looks like we might be moving ahead
would you like to you know read a script
and maybe you know come and talk about
it so I got the first episode draft then
and and read it and you know it was
funny because it it was quite give their
elements of what it is in what we did
but it's quite different it was again a
lot of action and
and yeah a lot of jokes and you know and
I met with Brian Alex and I honestly dad
the thing I didn't have any sense of the
my experience was sort of SNL writers
who have a very particular sort of style
and tone and this was sort of different
and it kind it did take me a minute sort
of just ative to this like oh this is
like really different and interesting so
yeah I met them maybe a few months after
that and I'm really I think what what we
hit it off on was once he actually
taught to start talking about our own
favorite films and answer what they felt
influenced them and then what I felt
like we could do the show like we sort
of came together and so realized that we
had similar intent for the whole thing
and and so then from there we three of
us sort of them developed the the plot
line physical size together and so and
figured it out which was a yeah as a fun
experience again as writers are
wonderfully collaborative that you know
there was no like they were always open
to notes and I was open to conversations
and it was a really fluid process of
entirely through which was which is
great well that's yeah I mean that was
probably incredibly important because if
you're going to then go over to a
country that I don't know if either or
any of you and visited before right and
really be fish out of water yeah who and
everything you would need yeah yeah well
it was also we as a whole things of
accelerators very quickly so I went sort
of I think for me meeting them for the
first time to maybe then I went to shut
documentary now that the second season
and then a right at the tail end of that
there was suddenly a we want to go shoot
this you know the entire series get in
ischl II it was just going to be a pilot
and then as I've know we think we're
going to a 24 which is going to pay for
the whole 6 for 6 episode I want to go
do it when the window is you know we got
to do it before winter hits really hard
in Romania
so yes suddenly I sort of found myself
you know racing towards Romania and then
we landed there and started prepped with
maybe two episodes complete scripts that
we had an outline for the whole season
but we hadn't yet so really finish the
script and so yeah we were as we're
prepping
those guys were sort of kept them locked
in a hotel room in
look at while I was out around location
scouting and literally sort of running
going like hey I found a you know is
amazing York City back part of this
studio I you know I think you know I
think that could be the finale episode
and and it was really and then also
meeting actors we were stopped casting
and you start to cure their anecdotes
and stories about the time period who
addressing or family members you know
stories and so it was a really cool
fluid thing that we're able to sort of
keep basically addressing and adapting
and sort of bringing those elements into
the scripts like that they weren't sort
of some sealed in a vault of narrative
that we can touch we were able to really
keep molding it as we going which again
crews done obviously don't love it when
you don't have a finished script once
you start prep because they also need to
know what they're doing and then you
know you can you can sort of reassure
them and tell them special no no this is
what the team's going to be like it is
it but until they see it on paper
oftentimes they just don't believe you
for good reason because oftentimes
things change but so they're you know it
definitely stressed people out a little
bit I think the Romanians especially if
they weren't used to work in that way
but but I think in the end it really
helped so it gives the show as a
particular Romanian flavor that we
probably couldn't have done if we just
written the entire thing before going
and you know just sort of turned it over
so yeah it was a good process amande did
you take a guide with you or an
interpreter I mean how would you even
know just some of the cult you know some
of the customs and things that
ingratiate you area I mean yeah
obviously would you know I did a lot of
research about that time period before
goings and then but then no I mean that
almost most of our crew you know really
spoke good English and so that wasn't
too much of an issue we had a local
production like a local studio that was
basically producing things for us who
are really collaborative and helpful as
well and guided us so I think Brian's
going to magically appear neck oh great
O'Brien thank you for joining us I
appreciate yeah absolutely be here real
quickly we were just curious how you got
started I know you had a film in was it
2011 with Jonah Hill that you wrote with
your
alessandra yes well actually I met
Alessandro at Columbia Film School where
he graduated with distinction and I
dropped out but we had already started
writing together and working together
and we started writing I guess my first
professional job was probably around
2005 or so we started working for Warner
Brothers and then we spent many years
doing a number of different you know
rewrites on scripts we do adaptations we
do punch ups and then you know you
altima taught an original that we will
consider that came out and it was a lot
it was a lot of writing a lot of hard
work to break in it's not easy but um
you know getting inside the studio
system was actually an advantage for us
in that we were essentially paid to work
on writing for a number of years and
hone skills and take on different genres
and sort of build up a toolbox of
writing so it was ultimately great but
it was a grind addition to it for sure I
know you've been writing together for
what is it over a decade or so yeah ah
gosh it's been a long time we we have
met in our first writing class at
Columbia and we just had similar taste
we liked each other's scripts and a
second year we we decided to try to
write something together which it turned
out to be much more fun to write with a
partner than to sit in a room by
yourself all day it's tough to find a
partner and a lot of times I think that
people try to do with friends but that
doesn't really work I think it's more
important that you see film or
television in the same way of similar
worldview similar sense of humor and so
we weren't really friends we just like
each other's work um but we've obviously
kind of become friends over the years
kind of we're very different people I if
you were here he would tell you that
also but um we have a mutual respect for
each other and we've had a great you
know probably almost 12 years or decades
plus at least writing
so great that's great I mean you hear
about in the startup world that
co-founder breakups are the number one
reason something will fail so it sounds
like it's least if you can work together
maybe being best friends the time is
maybe a detriment cuz you don't want to
hurt one other's feelings right
yeah no it's I'm not sure we just fell
into a natural rhythm of not having egos
and being able to criticize each other
or praise each other without you know
taking it personally and being able and
we also work you know very specific
hours so that we come in and we treat it
like a real job and then we're sort of
in the moment for you know six or eight
hours or hungry many hours writing a day
and then you know we kind of just go our
separate ways and yes we have become
friends because our wives are friends oh
that's why you became friends yeah yeah
uh yeah yeah I did ask him to be in my
wedding years ago and he said really
don't you want to ask somebody else to
be my writing partner but again maybe
that's there's a little bit of a
separation in some sense that works yeah
it's really just because he's lazy do
you I don't think it had anything to do
it
I'm just I'm just kidding he's very good
guy but yeah when we have we haven't a
very professional relationship or also
good friends I was wondering is one of
you more the rebellious writer and the
other one's more followers like certain
a guru you know and it's automatic I
think that's a that's a tough question
I'm not sure how to answer it because
we've just fallen into a natural working
relationship I think that Alex probably
is more like let's just do it to shut up
let's just do it and I like to you know
really challenge every idea and make
sure we're you know taking the right
path but it's a great mix because it
sort of keeps each other on our toes you
know I think that one more just like to
right away and the other maybe let's
just think about it for a second and
it's a good push-pull sure yeah opposite
personality works - yeah
so then with comrade detective how did
this come about how the idea um well we
grew up fans of you know eighties
entertainment that was ultimately kind
of propaganda sort of the red dawn type
movies and I love those movies we both
loved those movies growing up and you
know we thought about what it would be
like from the other side you know like a
Soviet perspective and sort of an
exploration of propaganda and you know
we looked at global television and we
kind of found this world that we didn't
really know existed even and there's a
there's a PBS documentary from the mid
80s about a University of Minnesota that
intercepted Soviet satellite sort of
network television and they studied it
for a year and they would do a show on
it every week and it was a fascinating
sort of parallel universe that you know
when I was a kid there were kids on the
other side of globe growing up with an
entirely different perspective and we
also found there was a show called
thirty cases of major Zeeman from
Czechoslovakia that was a show about a
communist detective and it was entirely
made by the state in order to prop up
communist ideals he was sort of like the
communist James Bond and we just thought
that you know that was I guess it
touched on early on but um once we came
around that we're going to make our own
fo sho
that's when you know Reese came on and
then we started developing the whole
thing together and you know when I'm
sort of a surprising and fun journey and
an interesting process of making
something that we presuppose existed and
then you know all the way from making a
show in Romania through the dubbing
process which was totally experimental
process as well yeah I know was
documentary now you're getting into the
mind of the original creator how was
that - for you I mean were you thinking
of some of that afterward you just like
said let's sit down and write this first
um we tried to write it from the from a
point of view of you know communist
filmmaker making something that's
propaganda I think that you you
naturally are grow up with it with a
worldview er sort of your own
indoctrination that's probably
impossible to entirely shed but we did
try to really think about it from the
inverse perspective of if we were making
something from an American point of view
and how do you take turns writing or do
you do they're like a favorite place you
go to together we probably spend about
90 percent of the time writing in the
same room we feel like it keeps us we're
moving ahead and also we talk through
everything first so we never really sit
down without knowing what's the other
ones doing and then we'll usually will
either break stuff up or one of them
will take the one of us will take the
first step then the other will come in
and just start rewriting it right away
we generally like to write what we call
a vomit draft just to try to get get
something out on paper right away and
that can sometimes be very close to what
ends up and sometimes it can be entirely
different but um it's it's important to
just start getting your thoughts out on
paper but yeah it's it's um it's that we
pretty much split up a lot of the duties
so until interest I don't even know this
before oh yeah
great what I'm really yeah anything
those curious who typed and put you that
type yeah I have a trick if we have a
deadline I generally just use the you're
faster I think I think I read once that
steps would do I could be wrong but I
think that II think Owen is the faster
type or so yes and a lot of the type
that's what I've read anyway but I'm but
he is he's like a magician so if there's
a deadline I usually use it and he's
completely onto it so he'll you
generally pushback or be like now it's
it's all you so it's it's a it's a trick
they use too many times but it'll still
pull it out every now and then
but yeah we it's it's a just a natural
flow situation isn't it you know there's
no rigid rules or but um yeah it's a
little bit tough to describe even I
guess so for someone who's never cast a
list talent before and this could be for
either of you how would you suggest that
they go about it and I realize it's it's
not a matter of just pointing a finger
of who they want but in terms of getting
things through the proper channels
either if you feel inclined inside sighs
it's funny cuz it um you know I think
having a analyst person involved in
project somehow helps I think obviously
I've been lucky because you know
studying SNL we're surrounded by it and
then you know if I started documentary
now with with Bill Hader and Fred
Armisen and Seth Meyers and so that
helped obviously opened doors and then
obviously this project these guys took
it to Channing and use on what is a
producer which you know again it
legitimate is you it tells other a less
people that it's okay to open that
attachment and have a look but but yeah
I mean you guys my own name as writers
um yeah it's a it's usually a process
generally you know unless you're you're
you know personal friends with with the
actor then usually go through a series
of you know they'll initially probably
go to their company and I mean in the
case of Channing it was you know we
brought it to free association along
with a 24 and we pitched you Peter
Kiernan and read Carolyn and and and
essentially they picked it up they just
really liked the idea and then we went
in and talked to Channing about it and
he liked it as well and that's a that
conversation led to us getting an a-list
director please Thomas oh no he was our
he was our collective first choice it's
completely true that never happens and
you know getting an act Oh text is is
generally a great thing it can it can
constrain you can need to have the right
like for this Channing was the perfect
person so you know it helps when when
when the project and the actor or the
talent really align but yet it's
generally a process of it's a tough
process yes you know I mean I think
anyone who's trying to get anything made
in Hollywood will tell you most of what
motivates obviously what's getting made
is the attachment of Steiner that's
where your money comes from and
guarantee audience no like oh so it's
like that everything is kind of riding
on that a lot of times we were lucky I
think in this show obviously because we
were basically go the actuals of you
know on the ground you know 12 13 hour
days shooting in the cold and all that
kind of stuff we didn't have to take an
a-list people from we had a list
Romanian actors there who you know so I
think you know enjoyed the fact that an
American production was coming and
shooting in Romania and you know they
were wonderful but you know here we had
the added benefit that we were just
calling up people and saying hey can
come you know being a dubbing booth for
a few hours one afternoon and so makes
life a little easier when you cancel ask
further the less I think I read in the
press notes where you said that most the
time in the US year you know your your
focus on finding that celebrity but for
the Romanian part of it it was but there
was more freedom with that oh yeah yeah
yeah no it was amazing to read yet just
to be able to go you know it's almost
like casting a play in you know some in
your local town and you know with it
like where you're just looking for the
who you imagine that character to be and
you know with no baggage of of well we
want it to be a Ryan Gosling type or
anything like that's not that you know
it's it's you we were just people
walking in a room and you can have would
immediately start having a reaction like
is you know and you know it was
interesting because obviously you know
these guys you know wrote these
characters and we develop them together
and so it was interesting also sort of
getting to then see what we all thought
these characters were in the process of
meeting these Romanian actors as they
came in and so to understand like
okay you saw members that said okay and
then I mean I really think like by
probably like nineteen ninety nine
percent of time I think we're all on the
same page I don't think there was any
long disagreements about who we chose so
yeah it was it was a really fun like
pure casting experience yeah it was
great
if I could do everything this minds and
job it afterwards to get it made I would
do it because yeah I'm great
and how long were you in Romania
shooting I think it's funny my wife's
told me I think it was 82 days that we
were there every day they do every night
probably right yeah it was a long time
we basically arrived very beginning of
October and left right before Christmas
pretty much yeah yeah right when the
winter in Romania was just just about
stuck getting lethal iost it was like
yeah yeah it was a great experience so
the flight over how long was that and
what was going over a flight back with
the footage what was going through your
mind I was on ER lash so it was sort of
wrap party straight to here we're going
from and we were at party we literally
wrapped I think at 6:30 a.m. a Monday
morning we had a wrap party Monday night
and then we flew out at 6:30 at early
the following morning and yeah I the
morning of departure I was woken up by
Brian phoning my room and I woke up
fully clothed on my bed and he's like
hey write what you need and I wasn't
packed or anything guy it was I got out
of that hotel room in about ten minutes
maybe less left a bunch of stuff I'm
sure and yeah we could got there but it
wasn't just me that our producer Brian
had told also waking up who was in his
underwear she measure one no I woke him
up saying really Michael another haired
for the UH yeah quick quick exit but uh
so yeah that was old it was a while time
it was it was a cathartic experience to
get to the end of shooting and to then
have a party with
you know remaining in cast and crew's
slot so you enjoyed it so it sounds like
the strategy you were just more
recuperating but then once you've got a
good night's sleep or a weeks worth of
sleep what was the strategy or did was
that already planned in terms of
bringing it to Amazon
oh yeah no I mean it was funny because
we we you know so we went out and shot
the show on spec a 24 you know paid for
it and took the risk but yeah we know
where it's going so then we shot it came
back and you know had a little break
over Christmas and then and instead
about just editing the Romanian show as
an original Iranian Romanian show so we
were cutting it in Romanian with
subtitles and we you know probably took
from I think by the end of February we
had all six episodes maybe was early
March all six episodes in Romanian cut
some way during that process maybe once
the first two episodes were done I think
we got words Amazon were either
interested or it was moving looking that
way
but yeah at the time when we started it
was just a let's start working on it and
see what we got it which is a totally
unorthodox way of going about it I mean
usually there's at least a pilot or you
know somebody who's going to air it in
advance but you know a 24 is a young
company with bold ideas and you know we
sort of we had a pilot we had Rhys we
had Channing and then the thought
process was sort of why why go to
Romania and just make a pilot when we
could you know probably make something
for you know not all not a large amount
of money and just do a whole six
episodes and then come back with that to
sell that which is which it you know
takes a lot of guts and give a 24 you
know huge amount of credit for that
right and there's the stress of not
knowing whether it'll happen and all the
time and money spent and I'm wondering
did anything in life prepare you for
that ahead of plan I know
Rishi talked about your job that you had
between the early days of being in New
York and the stress and balancing all
that
I would just say working in you know
studio system for ten years or whatever
toughen you up to the point where you
just you have to be prepared for all
sorts of scenarios often especially as a
writer rejection so at this point you
know it's still you it's still on your
mind and you're still hoping and I feel
like we you know we thought we were
making something you know really
interesting great and so you know it's
probably a little bit confident in my
better moments and I'm sure I had some
some darker moments that late at night
so um but but everybody was so enthused
and you know having such a great cast
having a guy like Reece behind the
camera you know definitely instill the
confidence in us but that sometimes it
was hard to come by in this business get
knocked down so much and things just
usually don't turn out as you planned as
much as you try to to you know harness
control of your work it can it can go
sideways at any moment so I think
ultimately love the fact you're getting
something made that you know that that's
the biggest hurdle is this for getting
someone to like give you the keys and
yeah go go make it I think then then it
is in your hands too obviously
deliver it but yeah if you're at that
stage then you know I think that's when
the momentum kicks in and and you know
you like I don't know that that's where
I feel like you can even though it
seemed obviously the stress begins of
trying to do it
you can also relax like okay right here
now and I think I think always knowing
how hard it is to get projects off the
ground here that yeah that's that first
day on set is like I was you always feel
lucky so you're actually there doing it
and not you know going to another
meeting and just hoping someone likes
you or something you know whatever so
yeah that's that's the tough bit and
then
yeah I knows that you just have to try
and stand behind what you're doing and
deliver it which you know conversate I'm
not trying to make it sound easy but
that's to me that sometimes the easier
side of it then yeah and getting the
project going in the beginning lastly
was there anyone from your past a mentor
or someone that you admired you've
watched from afar maybe that you just
really liked how they handled situations
or you liked how they did things or
their mindset and what was that kind of
always stuck with you even if you didn't
really consciously realize it well I
would say I had a personal mentor Jerry
Kass was a playwright from New York he
was a professor that Alex and I had at
Columbia who was a near dear friend who
unfortunately passed away some time ago
but but he was sort of a huge influence
because when I got to film school he was
one of the first you know older seasoned
writers to come to you and say you know
I think that you know what you're doing
is really great work and he was
incredibly Curt encouraging and he we
sort of became family he then you know
introduced us to his wife who's Delia
Efron was one of the upfront sisters and
she's amazing
Jerry was my son's Godfather and Delia
is my my son's godmother and so I'm
still very close with Delia but and
she's definitely filled some of that you
know space of Jerry's did that he used
to occupy but they've both been great to
us over the years so yeah so we had a
personal mentor and in terms of of
mentors from afar you know there's
probably a whole bunch maybe you haven't
I mean I could say for this project I
would say that there was a we've talked
to this before
the way that Stanley Kubrick you know he
started out thinking he was in a adapt
Red Alert
sort of a serious thriller look at
nuclear war and then the more he looked
at it the more absurd it was to him that
ultimately became dr. Strangelove and I
think that you know sometimes looking at
in this case at propaganda at
entertainment of propaganda the more we
looked more absurd it became to us so I
think that that least for this
particular project was probably a bit of
an inspiration from the far um in terms
of so yet direct mentalism I mentioned
Jim Signorelli he was the director sort
of you know kind of brought me to us and
Al and you know was really he'd been
around for a long time we've been the
director that since 1975 and so was just
this fascinating guy that knew
everybody's job on sets like he could
always answer if a crew member kingdom
said we can't do this he always had an
answer for it like his he he basically
been in that situation before and kind
of had a trick order so I definitely
learned a lot from him but then I was
also lucky that I I kind of grew up with
the crew that I eventually worked with
because I started as a PA at the film
unit and then you know then was the
light you know became a producer all the
individuals that would eventually sort
of start you know basically supporting
me once I started directing were all
people that you know when I was you know
young and silly and didn't understand
what was going on with with their you
know sort of teaching me and sharing
what was going so you know I think them
and seeing their interactions not only
with you know with me obviously but with
other directors I got to do that too you
know like that I would sort of I'd be
the one to come out and we you know we
worked to mm we had Jason Reitman come
in noble back in and officer Jim and
different people I'm getting to see this
about who they responded to an aspect of
you know what they felt like worked with
each person and all that kind of you
know those dynamics I you know
I don't know that was a really valuable
thing to have that relationship with
those people and sort of see what they
valued in the people that were sort of
you know in charge or you know they were
sort of leaping to battle with and as I
always you know kind of try to take the
lessons learned from that and and then
you know from afar
I think obviously there are there are
influences and people that I love you
know again we talked on this show
Brian DePalma and Roman Polanski you
know it would immediately you know
pretty important and Johnson Demi and I
mean full-time Sanderson was kind of
without that he remembered he was a sort
of watching Boogie Nights was the first
time I feel like my brain kind of
clicked to like was that seeking a
direct his hand actually at work you
know I would loved film and I grew up
you know it's Spielberg and I love those
universes but then there was something
in Boogie Nights I just remember I think
maybe I was just at the right age and
and so over to I suddenly was like
notice that the filmmaking just became
really apparent to me and what was
happening and so yeah there's you know
there's all moments like that I think
then you know that's what I love about
what doing being able to do this is that
it's a completely fluid industry and
that you you know you never know
everything you you know continually get
to learn new tricks from people and then
you know see new things and and also you
know there's constantly new content
coming out that is surprising you or and
teaching and showing you different ways
of seeing things and yes it's you know
you get the opportunities if either you
can keep adapting with it that there's
not there's no rulebook that says as
well as how you do it it's that's you
know that's not that it's tough at the
beginning when you start the fact there
is no rule book is the most infuriating
things like well what am i doing but
once you you know once you realize that
really it is it again it's you get
comfortable with your own sort of
understanding of things and you know can
sort of recognize that it is it's a
wonderful
you